c'est à mon sens le plus grand écrivain
français du moment c'est michel
houellebecq bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
là bonsoir tout le monde nous arrivait
de vacances là vous êtes bronzés non non
non c'est sous le maquillage enfin si
j'étais en vacances mais je suis pas
brosser
ouais si mon apparence ouais ça va
mouais
oui j'ai des soucis je fais des trucs
nouveaux
donc c'est toujours des soucis m arrive
on va en parler vous faites de la
chanson maintenant je sais pas si tout
le monde ici connaît michel houellebecq
en tous les cas c'est un écrivain
formidable
d'abord il avait écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelait extension du domaine de la
lutte qui est adepte de cinéma
d'ailleurs par philippe harel
ensuite il a fait les particules
élémentaires qui est un moment
extrêmement important et que je vous
conseille de lire si vous l'avez déjà
fait ça s'est vendu qu à trois cent
mille exemplaires
oui ou par non il ya encore donc
quelques millions de gens qui peuvent
l'acheter
ça a été traduit en 25 langues ce qui
prouve que a priori à quelque chose ça
devait être adapté au cinéma par pia
l'asse pas fait ça non
ce maître débuté au cinéma mais je suis
pas par qui alors les particules
élémentaires donc voilà pouvez l'acheter
vous publiez vous avez publié en
septembre naissance donc
vous dites on parle c'est un recueil de
poésie oui mais vous dit en parlant de
redessan je vais profiter de ma zoom
zoom manga ressent vite je vais profiter
de ma nouvelle notoriété pour est sorti
d essayer de sortir la poésie de son
ghetto bas tout le monde de oui oui des
cons
beaucoup de gens ont essayé ouais
moi j'essaye je suis pas le premier à
vous ai trouvé un système en tous les
cas pour sortir la poésie de son ghetto
mouillé c'est que vous avez un cd ben
oui c'est une bonne formule en faire de
la musique en même temps quand on trouve
la musique qui va ça peut pas arriver à
chaque fois là vous avez trouvé d'accord
ça va bertrand burgalat qui signe les
musiques et ça va être votre votre
présence au printemps de bourges va être
le 20 avril sans doute l'événement du
printemps de bourges alors voilà ouais
ça en fait c'est une vachement bonne
idée de mettre des poèmes en musique ce
qui est plus délicat c'est l'idée que
j'interprète moi même mais ça c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé donc si un
interprète quelconque à les connaître
eh ouais vaness les brèves de filles
alors
[Musique]
ça
cette chanson je peux l'écouter en
boucle mais j'aime beaucoup venez ça
mais mais mais je sais pas si j'ai écrit
des trucs bien pour pour les filles quoi
pour écouter un petit bout de playa
blanca et les fonds d'aidés sociales
[Musique]
le monde
incroyable mais vrai c'est michel
houellebecq l'auteur des particules
élémentaires qui chante comme quoi tout
est possible tout est possible au départ
tout est possible mais j'aimerais dire
aux autres muraille bien coûter deux
millions aussi l'adorent millions lui
j'aime beaucoup
si vous voulez voir houellebecq sur
scène donc il ya le 20 avril le
printemps de bourges
enfin vous faites une tournée oui ça
sera peut-être mieux parce que le sont
pas encore tout à fait au point
enfin on va essayer que ce soit bien
ouais c'est plus sûr on met fin mels et
3 mai à paris aux folies pigalle le 26
mai à lyon au transbordeur qui a prouvé
toute une une tournée limoges angoulême
toulouse bordeaux rennes vous faites
tout une tournée monaco voilà ben oui le
ca devrait mettre policiers pour t mais
est ce que vous arrivez dans la
littérature on vous souhaite le même
succès dans le disque parce que votre
bouquin elle sorti comme ça d'un seul
coup ça a été je me souviens la rentrée
81,18 les particules élémentaires
c'était le livre ça l'est toujours
d'ailleurs on en parle toujours au moins
une fois par semaine
ah ouais ouais une fois par semaine ne
vous suffit pas si si c'est énorme
ouais avec le recul michel houellebecq
comment vous réagissez aujourd'hui
comment vous considérez les polémiques
qui ont suivi la la parution des
particules élémentaires chez flammarion
mais c'est bien qu'ils aient des
polémiques en france son pays
sympathique pour que ça enfin il ya des
polémiques sur les livres il ya une
polémique avait dedans votive enfin
j'veux pas raconter votre liste cc dont
le jour ni l'heure
mais disons qu'il y avait plusieurs
thèmes et notamment une critique des
moeurs libérales et des dérive laxiste
de mai 68 qui est un peu le enfin le
thème si bien qu'à pas de critique du
film la parenthèse enchantée ou où joue
clotilde courau avec vincent elbaz
géraldine paillasse karin viard
voilà l'exemple même michel l'exemple
même alors d'un enfant de 68 là depuis
depuis le début de la soirée n'arrive
pas la tenir on sent bien qu'elle a été
qu elle a été élevée par des parents
baba cool c'est évident mais puisqu'il a
bien parlé de ça dans son bouquin
les sages là les sages depuis que vous
êtes là les sages
je sais pas les enfants se débrouillent
comme ils pouvaient bah oui exact vous
avez vous avait choqué d'abord en disant
ça parce que c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois où un auteur un écrivain
disait pas critiquer 68 ans 10 ans
charles manson serait pas été possible
168 donc d'un coup ça a mis tout le
monde devant ses responsabilités
là je caricature un peu mais c'est ça
l'esprit bapaume s'appelle malause way à
peine malheureusement été vous disiez en
dans votre bouquin puis dans les
interviews données par la suite que
finalement 68 c'était surtout pour vous
le triomphe de l'industrie du
divertissement
oui mais je maintiens mais c'est façon
quand on dit un truc pour la première
fois on peut toujours se poindre les
ennuis oui le mec a dit que la terre
classiquement les idées en mer du ciel
et puis alors il y avait aussi dans
votre bouquin qui a choqué les gens
c'est que c'est la première fois qu'on
décrivait des scènes érotiques non
satisfaisante parce qu'habituellement
dans les dents les films érotiques dans
les livres érotiques tout le monde jouit
tout le monde est content et vous vous
avez vous avez parlé de la sexualité
avec réalise non ouais mais elles sont
pas non satisfaisante non plus sur ses
moyens que celui c'est la réalité quoi
c'est comme dans la vie du satisfaisant
et du pas satisfaisant que c'est vrai
que c'est
non c'est pas de l'érotisme de sexualité
réel la sas a beaucoup choqué aussi
parce que c'est ouais des histoires de
sexe est toujours vachement bien tout le
monde est content
en fait le truc hein je vais vous dire
dites-moi michel le grand secret dans
l'histoire c'est que là le point
culminant des scènes n'est pas la
sexualité dans mes scènes sûr que ça
continue après donc la sexualité un
moment qu'intervient au milieu pas une
fin en soi quoi au wef assez parce que
dans tous les films qu'ils soient porno
ou sentimentaux ça finit toujours par le
point le plus sexuel alors que moi je
continue après fui je deviens moins
drôle tout ça est nécessaire que les
gens continuent à parler après et donc
la sexualité est intégré dans nos une
narration une réflexion sur les films
pornos vous dites que dans les années 70
les actrices de films porno était moins
jolie qu'aujourd'hui à quoi c'est dû à
votre avis on bosse assez simple c'est
parce que
maintenant tout le monde accepte de
fines faire des films pornos jean-pierre
plus de concurrence dans créé les plus
belles qui ont le leur que drissa 70 c
c'est celle qui voulait un peu qu'il ait
tourné quoi donc effectivement les films
pornos sont devenus moins réaliste du
coup parce que les filles sont plus
jolies quoi est ce qui a beaucoup choqué
les gens donc il ya eu effectivement
cette critique de 68 il ya eu cette
façon de raconter la sexualité d'une
façon très quotidienne comme ça très
réel est bien aussi toutes les mutations
du corps humain par exemple vous dites
vous faisait pas dans le bouquin mais
vous dites dans les interviews moi
l'idée d'un seul sexe ne semble pas mal
ça serait bien qu'on ait des clitoris et
des glands un peu partout sur le corps
des quatre heures de plaisir
il ya plein d'idées mais s'est plaint
dans l'hexagone ça aussi c'est bizarre
c'est l'introduction dans les michel
c'est vrai c'est l'introduction de la
science fiction dans le roman mais ça
non mais j'ai beaucoup chez politique
tout ça moi j'ai beaucoup choqué j'ai
beaucoup choqué parce que moi je n'étais
pas contre les mutations génétiques
ouais et donc le tout les trucs
génétique bizarre qu'on fait moi je
trouve que vous n'êtes pas content le
clonage vous non non je suis pas content
dit que si une tendance inéluctable
clonage et qui finira toute façon le
clonage humain finira pas sa propre
réseau de points et donc ça finira par
s'imposer comme mode de reproduction je
pense oui
ayez confiance alors on vous a accusé ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vous
accusez de véhicules et des fantasmes
ingénico c'est très vilain totalitaire
alors que vous vous placez la compassion
au dessus de toutes les qualités
humaines quelqu'un vraiment
compassionnel houellebecq à 20 ans il a
mis un coup de pied un pigeon et il dit
c'est ce que j'ai fait plus méchant dans
ma vie et je m'en veux encore est sympa
ben oui j'ai pas fait
et je peux fait pire ils en souffrent
toujours
mais oui ce pauvre pigeon je sais pas
c'était une femme ont changé la mairie
paille à bled un geste de postes postes
délinquants je sais pas pourquoi les
bons c'est vrai que les pigeons temps en
temps il a beaucoup c'est agaçant
appareil un jet pack et de la marine
c'est monsieur blanc si j'en fais moi il
ya eu votre livre a fait a fait scandale
et pour la bonne cause je dirais en
revanche il ya eu un scandale si vous
n'aviez pas le prix goncourt qua non
c'était l'idée de plus de plus sérieux
et de plus grave en parlant du prix
goncourt que vous n'avez pas eu
vous avez dit mon éditeur en
l'occurrence flammarion n'avait pas de
ligne budgétaire pour acheter les jurés
bah oui mais ça c'est pas un scoop enfin
bon il paraît que c'est un scoop qu'on
écrive un indice mais c'est la première
fois qu'un écrivain dit lui entendu des
éditeurs le dire donc je n'avais pas
l'impression de dire un truc si choquant
que ça moi je croyais que c'était tout
le monde tout le monde le savait déjà
quoi oui oui enfin ça se passe pas comme
ça c'est à dire qui leur donne leur
demande une préface et au vu de leur
pays la préface 5000 francs et leurs
prêts la préface 50 mille francs ça j'ai
dit ça un peu imprudemment mais je
pensais que tout le monde le savait
maintenant voyez enfin tout le monde le
sait mais personne ne disait alors il ya
une chose pour terminer avec vous michel
houellebecq qui vous resterez au delà de
tout ça comme le premier qui a dénoncé
les inégalités sexuelles qu'on avait
déjà dénoncé toutes les formes
d'inégalités et vous vous avez été le
premier l'a aussi à dire un peu comme
pour le concours était le premier à dire
que la compétition sexuelle et plus
sauvage que la computer que la
compétition capitaliste et qu'en fait il
ya aucune loi dans ce domaine
tous les coups sont permis c'est la loi
du plus fort ça aussi c'est quelque
chose était le premier à annoncer c'est
à dire qu'en fait là la vraie
compétition c'est la compétition
sexuelle et celle là il n'y a pas
d'égalité possible en plus ben non je
suis désolé d'avoir énoncé cette chose
des prix montent mais je n'ai rien à
retrancher là oui je sais c'est dix ans
plus tard évidemment il ya des clubs
échangistes c'est le com
il me sexuelle c'est l'offre oui faut
déjà pour l'occasion voilà c'est fait
d'échangistes m'en fasse tuer alors la
compétition en revanche c'est d'ailleurs
la discothèque c'est la compétition et
c'est dur on est faux pas c'est vrai que
l'on est on est samedi vers 1h du matin
il ya probablement des gens qui rentrent
des prix mais il sent sur canal en train
de regarder si bien on va alors vous
savez qu'on ne bouge pas paru jean galle
êtes au courant j'ai pas envie de bouger
sèche le savent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux faire une interview fin du monde
que vous êtes quelqu'un de spécial
mangue et comme on vient de le voir john
carew fin du monde alors c'est la fin du
monde michel oui les cordeaux c'est la
fin du monde si vous deviez sauver un
livre moi je prendrais la bible ouais
parce que bon c'est pas abouti mais on
peut en faire plein à partir de la bible
donc c'est très générateur quoi y'a
plein de petites histoires un peu ça a
déjà beaucoup servi pour refaire des
livres à partir de 1 si vous deviez
sauver un animal
le bichon frisé le bichon frisé oui vous
aimez les bichons frisés oui sa
magnifique voix votre grand mère avait
un bichon frisé baisse et comme c'est un
tout petit chien c'est comme une peluche
c'est toujours le petit mais non ça boit
pas bon du tout n'ont presque pas et ça
vous sautent dessus ça vous laisse en
fait c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
aussi je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être les l'idée de la preuve
mathématique
ouais ça c'est bien ça beaucoup s'est
écrié nous simplifie la question
suivante un disque est un trop le vôtre
non non non en béton haut de ses murs un
film peut-être murnau l'aurore oui si
vous aviez sauver un sexe spécial non
non mais ça veut dire ça se pose même
pas nous drogue
ben moi je dirais le tabac ça l'air de
rien mais c'est bien si vous deviez
sauver un homme politique ça serait qui
du béribéri 60 moi je sais pas j'ai rien
contre je
j'ai plaisir à monsieur mois ou beaucoup
nettement j'aime bien chevènement mai
désolé désolé pour le public
vous êtes élu un coup de pied comme un
pigeon non j'aime bien chevènement
chevènement ah ouais ouais je trouve
qu'il est courageux
malaysia le bon dieu qui l'a sauvé une
fois il ya des côtés pierre aussi
écouter pierre on rallume
maintenant je voulais retrouver la star
de la rentrée
michel houellebecq quartier du blanc
je veux montrer à savoir deux maliens se
fout de moi je me sens mal mais je suis
jeune et je me reconnais que je veux
montrer ce soir
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde non
pas en tant compte tenu de ce que vous
dites dans votre bouquin au sujet de la
concurrence ça aurait été difficile d'y
aller non non je pu effectivement jeu
oui je suis dur avec fuji elle mais il
met le mérite alors vous publié chez
fayard la possibilité d'une île donc
c'est l'événement littéraire médiatique
commercial de la rentrée votre livre
écrase d'ailleurs cette cette rentrée et
les 650 autres romans de la rentrée sont
un peu réduits au rang de figurants non
oui mais c'est pas de ma faute
j'avais dit longtemps l'avant ce que je
publie un livre plus beau là j'ai décidé
de
d'arrêter de faire de la fausse modestie
parce que ça se verrait donc c'est vrai
que mon livre est bon
[Musique]
oui c'est un peu normal qu'il écrase la
rentrée oui c'est pas de ma faute je
veux dire totalement s'est déclenché
beaucoup d'années dans tous les cas non
bah oui mais ça aussi c'est normal on
peut pas on ne peut pas en vouloir au
moins la jalousie est un sentiment
humain que je comprends parfaitement
avec lequel je sympathise même et que je
suis toujours prêt à pardonner vraiment
l'art au delà du phénomène
houellebecq on va parler du livre est
d'abord le pitch donc la possibilité
d'une île raconte la vie de dalian qui
est un être humain qui viennent pas
vraiment à notre époque un qui vit dans
une dans une dizaine d'années à peu près
oui oui oui les quelques légères
augmentations de phénomènes déjà
visibles comme mauvais traitements aux
vieux ce genre de choses ce qu'on a vu
apparaître dans la canicule de 2003 oui
oui les l'effarante
inhumanité en phase avec les quais dans
laquelle on finit ses jours quoi le pi
l'islamisme est moins moins présent dit
c'est un peu comme le punk
c'était très fort c'est redescendu et
maintenant pour garder une comparaison
musical c'est un peu comme la new wave
quoi oui oui
ouais ouais bon se peler thermidor c'est
pas paraître bien optimiste mais enfin
c'est ce que je pense c'est sa main ça
m'est venu à l'esprit en voyant des des
filles très voilé ce que le but c'était
de faire peur craint un peu comme le but
des punks c'est de faire peur aux gens
normaux manqué en 2015 les filles ont
toujours dévoilement fins et plus
décoratif vous dis oui oui et puis bon
tout ça tout ça s'efface pop donc je
parie sur un sur le fait que les choses
se calment et qui est bon par
l'intermédiaire de la jeunesse un geek
envie de liberté d'une race aussi alors
ce dernier albi donc en 2015 à peu près
et sa vie est lu et commenté
deux millénaires plus tard par ses
clones des néo l'humain que vous appelez
daniel 24 et daniel 25 alors eu en fait
ils ont pu besoin de se nourrir et vivre
par photosynthèse
oui je ils ont juste besoin d'eux comme
les plantes de sol minéraux et d'eau et
ils ont beaucoup moins
bon à part ça il ya des il ya des mâles
et des femelles comme les vives sol
reliées par un
bon à l'internet franchement améliorée
et ils ont un entraînement qui consiste
en gros d'abord à faire des exercices
pour obtenir la paix le calme
l'absence de désir et de souffrances
dont quelque chose de très inspiré du
bouddhisme
par ailleurs il étudie la biographie de
leurs prédécesseurs
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils étudient la
vie de daniel 1 pour essayer de tirer
parti de leurs échecs et de leurs
souffrances pour ne pas vivre la même
chose alors daniel hains donc celui qui
vit dans dix ans c'est un humoriste à
succès un mix entre eux dieudonné bigard
pierre desproges
mais quelque chose de pire que tout ça
réuni parce que il est d'un cynisme
total serre que dieudonné je pense que
c'est pas purement de la provocation
chez lui je pense qu'ils croient
vraiment à la cause palestinienne est
malheureusement qu il est peut être
aussi devenu antisémites du coup alors
que daniel lui les prêts a allumé tout
le monde du moment qui pense que ça peut
être marrant à l'est dé misogynie
affolante
il ya cette fameuse van tu sais comment
on appelle le gras qu'il ya autour du
vagin la femme
oui oui oui et il est misogyne mais il
est une espèce de
il est toujours sur le fil du rasoir que
ça c'est un bon pro très très bon procès
y provoque mais ça reste juste à temps
et gagne plein de fric ouais
à un moment il rajoute un petit peu
d'anti sémitisme parce que ça puisque
c'est bien alors il fait un film porno
qui s'appelle brut/mois la bande de gaza
mon rôle de l'ange g donc ils essayent
toujours de surfer quand même pour
rester politiquement correct dans le
politiquement incorrect
si on cela que c'est une légère
anticipation parce qu'on est
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle il y aura
un espèce de carton ou je ne sais quoi
mais je suppose que le l'humour qui a
déjà beaucoup de droits beaucoup c'est
un peu n'importe quoi vont en gagner
encore un peu plus et lui se moque de
tout ce qui l'intéressé c'est quoi
d'ailleurs c'est le succès ce qui est
terrible c'est que malgré ses dérapages
racistes misogynes
finalement il a une bonne image auprès
de la presse il a des bonnes critiques
dont elle dit vous des bonnes critiques
dans le télérama
il passe pour un homme de gauche oui
mais il réussit par boris moque pas mal
aussi de des gens d'extrême droite vous
dites qu'en fait que le seul contenu
résiduelle de la gauche c'est l'anti
racisme oui mais c'est vrai que la com
com contenu de la gauche à un moment
donné il ya eu on peut s'en souvenir il
ya eu comment dire une société
partageuse quoi mais tout ça
complètement disparu la gauche est
devenu libéral
ensuite il ya eu il est resté une espèce
de libertarisme mais c'est fini c'est la
gauche et anti drogue antitabac donc
belle est la seule cause sur laquelle
parce qu'il faut quand même des causes
un peu mobilisatrice affaires sur
lesquelles on arrive on arrive à mettre
d'accord la gauche etc c'est l'anti
racisme que vous appelez le racisme anti
blanc oui parce qu'il ya une sorte de au
fond de désir désir de pas être blanc
faye et cette culpabilité manipulatrice
et un peu louche mais donc il arrive à
sa propre surprise est encore considéré
comme un homme de gauche et même comme
un humaniste et pourtant les droits de
l'homme et s'en fout il dit quand aux
droits de l'homme rien à [ __ ] à peine
si je parviens à m'intéresser aux droits
de ma que oui c'est un type finalement
qui a écrémé dit vous tous les créneaux
porteurs le racisme la pédophilie la
torture le cannibalisme le parricide
avec un certain succès donc oui et à 47
ans il est complètement lessivé l'on
peut plus le type qui ait conscience de
conscience de sa propre médiocrité où il
a conscience d'être de [ __ ] quoi être
d'être plus d'être plus ta bile de pas
alors il a 47 ans il est lessivé vous
dites la vie commence à 50 ans c'est
vrai à ceux ci payent qu'elle se termine
à 40 quoi donc à 47 il et il est bon il
tient il tient limite quoi enfin il en a
il en a marre de ce qu'il fait il en ai
marre de son public qui supporte plus le
rire ce qui est quand même grave pour un
comique c'est c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose de méchant dans le rire et
moi c'est que j'ai déclaré c'est vrai
que j'avais beaucoup été impressionnée
par quelqu'un qui était naturel
chaleureux ouvert et qui avait connu de
funès et lui demande de parler de de
funès voit son visage change et regin
dit ah oui lui les est vraiment triste
et c'est impressionnant parce que de
finesse et le comique le plus gentil le
plus tout public qu'on puisse imaginer
il semble bien que quelqu'un qui arrive
qui arrive à être comics et qui s'est
mécaniquement comme on peu fait rire les
gens qui a trouvé succe ce secret là ce
soit un secret triste parce que la smat
obligé de très bien connaître la nature
humaine
oui on est obligé de très bien connaître
nature humaine on s'interdit d'exprimer
tout événement peut être vu comme
comique ou comme tragique kouassi ont vu
mon service interdit d'exprimer le côté
tragique et apparemment ce fini pour
vous rendre volume très triste alors
donc lessivé il se retire en espagne
dans une maison de 27 pièces au nord
d'almeria mais tient pas du tout compte
de la beauté du lieu de ça au cas ça
aucun effet sur lui
e
il s'aperçoit que ça suffit pas que le
lieu peut être beau mais n'y peut rien
en faire en fait de cette de cette
beauté il dit à un moment donné que s'il
avait un réel tempérament artistique il
pourrait faire quelque chose cette
beauté des tableaux je ne sais pas
prenez pas le k way gens qui s'ennuient
et il vit donc avec isabelle qui est une
rédactrice en chef d'un magazine de mode
qui s'appelle lolita voilà mais il
s'ennuie parce qu'il n'a pas envie de
faire des enfants
non il n'a pas envie de faire des
enfants il n'est pas pourquoi parce
qu'il veut pas imposer finalement à
d'autres êtres le calvaire d'une
existence terrestre ya un passage où
c'est vrai je me suis moi même posé la
question pourquoi les pourquoi les bébés
hurle aux points alors ça arrive pas du
tout aux bébés chats chiens et un cochon
et je pense qu'il ya un défaut quelque
part peut-être c'est une erreur de
perdre les poils
enfin je ne sais pas le mais bon là ça
laisse le côté de la science fiction
commence à arriver il dit quelque chose
qui va pas d'hellemmes pas les enfants
il dit c'est l'enfance est une sorte de
nains vicieux d'une cruauté ine et
d'ailleurs les animaux domestiques en
ont peur c'est vrai que l'enfant
manifeste sa personnalité sa volonté de
dominer son entourage de manière
violente
mais pire que ça au fond sicile eurent
le bébé c'est parce qu'il souffre je
pense réellement qu'on est trop sensible
la douleur que la douleur physique va au
delà de sens de son sa nature de signal
et il ya quelque chose qui va pas au
fond on sent quelque chose de
déséquilibrer dès le départ chez l'être
humain
alors daniel et isabelle ne font pas
d'enfant et le grand événement c'est
quand il recueille un chien un dénommé
fox un soir au bord d'une autoroute et
là vous dites c'est le meilleur amour
c'est l'amour inconditionnel parce que
finalement le chien il n'attend rien en
l'échangé vous aiment vraiment oui puis
et puis ce qui est assez bon tout le
monde
toute personne ayant vécu en couple
c'est qu'il n'est pas forcément facile
de rendre le conjoint alors que le chien
c'est possible même s'ils ont animé des
meilleures intentions du monde le
bonheur de l'autre n'est pas garanti
alors qu'avec un chien ça peut arriver
et en fait ah ben ça arrive c'est assez
facile de réussir le but par des maîtres
y arrivent eux que c'est beaucoup un
vous êtes heureux avec clément oh oui
parce que je sais qu'il est heureux et
donc gg ce pouvoir là ouais vous rendez
quelqu'un fouille ou bien être heureux
alors qu'avec un enfant se serait pas
aussi évident c'est pas aussi évident
en plus l'éducation plus facile
concrètement c'est éduquer plus
rapidement alors entre daniel et
isabelle l'amour physique s'étiole
rapidement 8 mai au pastis tranxène ce
qui est quand même un cocktail
parfaitement houellebecq ja oui moi
c'est une vie c'est une nuit
particulièrement dur où il s'aperçoit
que en fait elle aime pas vraiment
l'amour physique et disent oui ça pour
le faire plaisir mais elle aime pas la
jouissance parce qu'elle est le problème
d'isabelle dans ce livre c'est qu'elle
est un peu trop noirci elle a été très
très très belle elle encore pas mal du
tout mais vous savez les gens qui sont
trop beaux finalement parfois du mal
avec l'amour physique parce que ça les
déforme way the sky il est mieux offrir
une image admirait weepu offre une image
glace est calme
la beauté va toujours avec une certaine
froideur quand même et là c'est terrible
pour lui parce que lui c'est ce qu'il
préfère c'est celle là c'est la seule
chose qui dans la vie motive encore un
et isabelle paris la trompe pas c'est ça
qui n'attendent pas du tout elle part
parce qu'elle sent qu elle en train de
se dégrader physiquement et précipite
ses propres dégradation pour une
surconsommation 2.3 elle prend 20 kg et
provin kg 1
mais au départ c'est elle qui laisse
tomber ouais c'est ça qui est l'art lui
très malheureusement il tombe sur une
dénommée esther nous appeler la belle
qu'à 22 ans et qui va lui rendre la vie
par le sexe quoi on comprend qu'ils
aient à ce monde sa vie où on commence à
en vivre ce qui va être un bonheur total
il sait qu'ils veulent perdre il sait
aussi que ce bonheur est si fort que sa
perte veulent tuer cirque et esther est
vraiment ils s'engagent là-dedans
sachant que c'est sa dernière histoire
car vous avez des phrases formidable la
vie sexuelle de l'homme se décompose en
deux phases la première où il éjacule
trop tôt la deuxième
il arrive plus à bander et le problème
de daniel avec esther c'est qu'en fait
qu'ils se retrouvent dans la première
phase en fait il éjacule trop tôt on y
trouve une crème will ils retardent
d'éjaculer comptant déjà il est content
de revenir la première fois le premier
tour et exaspère bon en fait nous mais
il ya de grands moments de bonheur dans
ce livre avec est déjà fait il trouve
une crème qui
oui on fait des choses maintenant quand
même faut pas nier il ya le progrès
technique pour retarder le accusations
et donc s'en suit une période de bonheur
très intense
et puis et puis l'assaut s'étiole parce
que ce qu'il est vieux ce qui est
terrible c'est que quand il peut lui
faire ce qu'il veut à cette fille mais
chaque fois qu'il veut l'embrasser sur
les lèvres
elle se détourne un peu commune comme
une prostituée et un moment elle doit le
présenter à sa soeur et elle ne lui
présente pas sa soeur parce que parce
qu'il est vieux donc lui se rend compte
de sa wii face skis ce qu'ils
craignaient ça se vérifie et puis là
mais quand on est vieux on a eu plein de
soucis dans sa vie enfin plus rien ne
vous amuse qu'il peut pas il veut faire
partie de son groupe de jeunes s'est pas
en fait c'est pas le sexe puisque qu'il
casse dans l'histoire ouais c'est le
fait que simplement il a plu l'énergie
la l'enthousiaste ont fait il est il est
trop sage trop troussage vous ne pas
trop résignée trop trop vieux et vous
dites dans le monde moderne
on pouvait être échangiste bi trans
zoophile sm
mais il était interdit d'être vieux et
les jeunes que c'est le début de sa vie
amoureuse c'est tout et lui c'est la
faune voir le problème c'est qu isabelle
n'aime pas c'est le sexe et esther
n'aime pas c'est l'amour voilà c'est
tout le dilemme pour ester l'amour c'est
sans divertissement avant tout y'a pas
d'un d'implication personnelle penser
que ses propres aux jeunes d'aujourd'hui
il est possible que l'amour soit mort
que ce soit après dieu ça fait 2-1
oui ça fait beaucoup je sais pas si les
jeunes ont envie d'aimer ou pas je peux
jeune je peux pas me prononcer mais
alors là c'est terrible parce que donc
plus d'isabelle plus d'esther et la plus
que son chien dans l'ombre fox et il se
réfugie chez les elohim it
alors c'est une secte évidemment
directement inspirée des raéliens et ça
vient d'une histoire insensée c'est que
dans la bible dieu s'appelle elohim qui
est un pluriel
veut dire les anges et effectivement
depuis de nombreuses années et à vendre
à l avant claude vorilhon il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont dit qu'en fait le dieu
de la bible c'était les elohim les anges
c'était des extraterrestres bon ça c'est
le début c'est le début du dogme c'est
plus ou moins rendu compte que ce qui
était accordée aux extraterrestres à
dire le pouvoir de créer et de manipuler
la vie les hommes étaient en train d'y
arriver au même techniquement sans sens
extraterrestres et donc la grosse
promesse là hello i meet est en fait la
promesse classique des religions s'est
rapporté à tout le monde l'immortalité
et la jeunesse éternelle
ouais vous dit que c'est une philosophie
très adapté au monde moderne parce que
d'abord une grande permissivité sexuelle
à l'intérieur de la secte et ensuite
elle promet une immortalité palpable
enfin c'est pas une mortalité spirituel
c'est une immortalité physique
en fait oui voilà il n'y a pas besoin de
croire grand show et deux aides
extraordinaires et s'est adaptée aux
progrès techniques vous dites qu'une
religion c'est une secte qui a réussi
mais vous vite sérieusement
ah bah oui mais ça c'est si on voit les
choses honnêtement si on voit le départ
des religions c'est vrai que ça se
présente vraiment comme une secte se
dire un petit groupe dissident par
rapport à une religion
une grosse religion dont ben al'inverse
on ne peut pas prévoir c'est une secte l
heure actuelle on peut devenir une
religion de grande diffusion
vous le connaissez rahal oui claude
vorilhon oui c'est sympa oui plutôt et
un cri rue louis ii est allé le voir
vous avez étudié
oui vous avez vous allez passer du temps
avec les raëliens pour écrire vote libre
évidemment pour étudier mais aussi parce
que vous êtes intéressé réellement barça
mais je suis intéressé par les parures
religion général 1 et là je cherchais
une secte qui soit pas complètement
grotesque comme ces gens qui croient que
l'oignon correspond symboliquement à
différents stades de développement enfin
quelque chose qui qu'ils puissent quand
même pas être immédiatement ridicule et
leurs histoires de clonage là parce
qu'il ya deux ans ils ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient ou qu'ils avaient réalisés à un
clonage humain
elle a par contre j'ai franchement des
doutes c'est vrai que aussi dit toute
façon on n'est pas loin des rives ou dit
toute façon tout ce que la science
permet sera réalisé oui ce qui ressort
du livre quand même
michel sait si vous avez ni respect ni
compassion pour pour l'humanité croyait
même une haine de l'humanité et même je
dirais une haine de la part d'humanité
qui est en vous avant vous l'humanité
les misérables et les humains quand on
lit votre bouquin on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu des mammifères dans
un zoo dans le fameux parc humain
en même temps ils me sont sympathiques
c'est c'est toujours eux il n'ya pas bon
c'est comme dans plusieurs de mes livres
il n'y a pas de nier pas de vraie
solution c'est le désir n'est pas une
solution mais le nom désir non plus
donc ces mammifères auquel vous réduisez
les humains vous dites sont en quête de
sexe de fun et finalement vous dites à
moins de kills me dit ce sont des kits
se définit oui je me serais qui est plus
que des kits plus ou moins vieux way
disons que bon ça c'est foutu je veux
dire il y aura plus de il y aura plus de
dignité à la vieillesse faux pas il faut
pas y compter
ça n'arrivera plus parce que tout ça a
perdu son sens et sa reposer sur un
système de succession des générations de
choses à transmettre sa s'intégrer dans
une religion qui chapeautait le tout
donc ça on le retrouvera plus plus
jamais alors ça se vend bien la
possibilité d'une île longue segment des
300 par jour chez virgin le davinci code
à la meilleure époque en vendée soixante
dix par jour et amélie nothomb 50 canton
quand même
ah mais oui je suis content mais ça
m'effraie un peu le scan and it avec le
davinci code mais bon je suis content
ouais ça se vend bien s'est traduit dans
36 pays
vous êtes déçu par l'accueil de la
presse française finalement non parce
que nul n'est prophète en son pays c'est
ce genre de choses c'est basique mais
c'est vrai qu'on en veuille je comprends
je ne vais pas jouer page ou bien
voyez-vous leurs êtres aimés en plus
ouais vous ne croyez pas que les
journalistes on était énervé par le fait
qu'ils aient très peu de gens qui a eu
le bouquin qui eut cet embargo sur votre
livre bon c'est vrai que si des gens au
bout de trois articles de crise que des
conneries sur moi soit bonne il envoie
une quatrième fois
je veux dire il ya des gens qui meurent
jamais ouais vous avez très peu
d'interviews cette rareté des interviews
c'est une façon de vous protéger contre
vos dérapages en vue du prix goncourt
non c'est pareil il ya des gens qui se
vaut pas le coup de polluer au pitch
façon je veux dire si je faisais
énormément d'interviews me reprocherait
aussi j'ai l'impression que je suis à un
stade ou quoi que je fasse
ouais ce sera d'abord perçue comme très
très mal un rôle à la caisse qu'il force
ou alain qu il fait énormément interview
genre qu'est ce qu'il est fort il fait
rien donc autant que je fasse ce que
j'ai au fils c'est à dire faire des
interviews que les gens à qui j'ai envie
d'en vous remercie mais c'est vrai que
par exemple le figaro c'était très dur
avec eux vous avez dit que vous refusiez
désormais tout une interview au figaro
pendant la durée de votre vie littéraire
non mais là c'est un peu exagéré il ya
eu des mises en cause même peut pas
seulement de moi parce que moi c'est
aussi le signe évident de gens de ma
famille il y avait des trucs que j'ai
pas voici le ferai pas qu'on a nettement
voici points
hésiterez et à ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'il y avait des publicités qui était
passé dans le point dans l'express dans
le figaro vous avait annulé et vous avez
gardé seulement des publicités d'anciens
2008 chez en 2007 j'ai insisté pour
avoir un chien 2000 c'est bien c'est un
ami mais pour les pour les maîtres de
chiens c'est la meilleure revue avait il
ya d'excellents dossiers techniques sûr
on est ni au courant dès qu'il ya une
nouvelle un nouveau parasite ou fait
rien on se bouge pour mieux sérieusement
ça vous fait quoi de pas être reconnu
comme le grand écrivain
vous êtes michel houellebecq je suis pas
inquiet sur l'avenir du l'avenir du
jugement sur les livres quoi c'est pas
vrai que c'est injuste un phénomène
commercial selon demain ce livre sera
lui longtemps
non je suis rassuré vraiment la merci en
est heureux de voir heureux est
maintenant interdit aux apps haidar
[Musique]
alors michel houellebecq qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce moment
c'est sûrement gré des dents qui tombe
parce qu'elle avait un truc temporaire 1
et si cette fois ci ça tombe avant que
j'aie le temps de refaire un truc
définitive et je vais beaucoup merdé
dans les lectures ça va siffler je fais
des lectures en public j'adore ça là
quel compliment qui vous énerve le plus
je crois que c'est peut-être quand on me
dit que je suis gentil quelle est la
qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir on
sait sûrement l'impossibilité de mentir
parce que moi ça m'a alors le carrément
littéraire moi ça m'a qu'est-ce que j'en
ai bavé dans les émissions où il on est
sommé de dire son avis sur le livre des
autres on pense du mal c'est horrible en
écrivain pardonne jamais un comme de
démolition public
quel est le talent que vous avez mais
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir longtemps
je me trouve trop intelligent et je
mettrai à dire que j'envisage trop de
possibilités quoi quels défauts aimeriez
vous avoir
je sais pas s'ils sont des faux
j'aimerais bien plus plus primaires plus
instinctif plus immédiat on dit que vous
êtes radin c'est vrai euh non ça je
crois que c'est pas vrai ouais je sais
pas pourquoi on dit ça d'ailleurs simple
maintenant de me rappeler ce que vous
dites que ces paroles qui ne voudriez
vous pas avoir comme fans j'aimerais pas
tellement avoir brillé comme fan ça me
ce métier très bon le nouveau roman vous
en pensez quoi
ensuite la merde a carrément canon il ne
reste rien par qui aimeriez-vous être
détesté b j'aimerais bien que les
écologistes répondait mais agression
permanente
ce que j'aime pas tellement le
la pensée écologie ça me dégoûte un peu
mais j'ai beau agresser les écologistes
s'ils réagissent pas pourquoi ça me
dégoûte
parce que je suis resté très
baudelairien chercher tout ce qui est
naturel ou ne trouvent rien que
d'affreux quelle est la meilleure
mauvaises critiques qu'on vous ait fait
c'est peut-être une critique de julian
barnes sur plateforme way qui a dit quoi
en gros je fais je fais trop de
concession à l'émotion facile quoi je
perds un peu d'insolence bonnes
critiques
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour arriver à vous séduire
maladroite ça marche toujours moi je me
souviens une du bon flic j'ai pas j'ai
pas du tout ça use était une histoire
d'amour par la suite mais une une
stallone scott est la première fois qu
elle m'a vu il était très ému de me vois
en france où il a neigé en hauteur elle
renversait carrément la bouteille de vin
sur moi je trouvais ça adorable l'été
l'an passé vous aimez juillet bon ce qui
a évidemment faux nom et ce rien passé
mais la maladresse monsieur oui qu'est
ce que l'avenir nous dira pas sûr vous
ne dira pas si j'ai été heureux ou non
ça restera indécidable jusqu'au bout
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez jamais dit à
personne a déjà je vais te tuer ouais
parce que
ce que je pense que si je l'avais dit je
l'aurais fait est que j'ai eu envie mais
mais non j'ai l'intégrer l'interdît
moral de meurtre a été le plus fort
quelle est la question qu il ne faut pas
que je vous pose et se serait peut-être
qui je vais parce que j'ai pas ce que
j'aurais des réponses et que j'ai envie
d'oublier
en fait j'ai envie d'être apaisé de
d'oublier je crois pas ou je crois
beaucoup au pardon c'est un concept
assez criquioche passé chrétien mais
j'ai envie de vous voyez plus à l'oubli
quand pardon oui honnêtement oui et ça
concernerait votre mère par exemple ça
pourrait mais il ya d'autres personnes
mais justement c'est les questions n'en
parlons pas merci très heureux merci
beaucoup michel
[Musique]